[Applause]
[Music]
Romania might be the first country in
the world to legalize corruption yes you
heard that right in January 2017 the
Romanian Parliament passed an ordinance
which allowed politicians to accept
bribes of almost $50,000 these bribes
could happen without any kind of legal
repercussions whatsoever now as you can
imagine this infamous ordinance triggers
one of the biggest political
demonstrations that the country has seen
for over 20 years the protest led to the
government suspending the law
temporarily but even after this protest
continued Romanians their rather used to
living in Europe's most corrupt country
and this ignominious decree was the
final straw that broke the camel's back
but the big question is how did they get
to this point and what's going on in the
country that could make its government
pass this kind of law without feeling
any sort of shame well today we're
getting down to this question but before
we do that let's take a look at the
history
[Music]
the European North Korea he calls
understand romanian history without
knowing it our Nicolae Ceausescu the
European Kim Jong
now other neighboring countries like
Hungary or Bulgaria have suffered
communist dictatorships - that the story
of Romania is special since cherisheth
coup came to power in 1974 his country
has been isolated from the rest and even
from the Soviet Union itself soon even
food started to become scarce while
citizens had their meals rationed by the
state Chiao Chesky spent money building
sparrow like palaces for instance here
is the Parliament of Bucharest the built
in 1983 and the names of the biggest
administrative building in the entire
world
this is especially amazing if we take
into account that the Romanian
population is no bigger than 22 million
inhabitants during the construction of
the building more than 20,000 people
were employed and around 3,000 died of
exhaustion but not only that coughs
enforced his citizens to participate in
parades and massive shows to praise his
own image in of a dishtowel member of
the partiers of chicken stock mrs nazife
at this party Victor Arce researchers
are a very shy immediate family's
internal change a certain summation will
no longer make arrests just like his
north korean comrades Ceausescu was a
master in the art of political
repression during 1980s an estimate of 1
in every 30 Romanians belongs to the
political police it could be your
neighbor
your hairdresser or anyone really
meaning any time you said something bad
about the leader you could end up
spending the rest of your days in jail
simply just disappear nonetheless
despite all of this being a dictator
needs not a safe job
[Music]
this footage is from Chow at KU the last
speech which took place on the 21st of
December 1989 look at his facial
expression and how it starts to tremble
it was at this moment that the audience
started to boo him
this is how the biggest protest in
Romanian history started thousands of
citizens stepped out on the streets with
national flags where the communist
symbols had been cut out three days
later on Christmas Day of that year
Nicolae Ceausescu died next to his wife
killed by his own party colleagues his
last words were
history will Avenger
and so now you might be wondering well
what happened next the truth is in such
an oppressive regime as child Cheska's
there were no opposition needed
whatsoever just innately comparison in
Poland when the communist regime fell
there were powerful leaders like less
well ASA who has much popular support
and helps write a brand new constitution
for the country nevertheless eveything
succeeded Ceausescu in Romania well that
would be his own party comrade more
exactly that would be the man whom you
see on the screen now and his name is
young EBS cute as you can imagine this
government was not willing to give up
the luxuries that they had during church
a few times so I always happens in cases
like this the Romanian regime changed
but just a little of course the new
constitution allow the other parties to
run for elections then the old Communist
Party changed its name to the social
democratic party but the high ranking
officials that ruled the country during
these dictatorships kept their power
during the 1990s and the 2000 so as you
probably know if power corrupts wealth
absolute power it corrupts absolutely
for a better understanding of this in
1995 50% of the Polish economy was
already in private hands but in Romania
this figure with only 35% so let's have
a look at an example let's take two car
manufacturers Czechoslovakia had a
state-owned factory Skoda that was
privatized in 1992 by sharing the under
ship among the workers its Romanian
counterpart Dacia was not privatized
until 1997 and instead of doing it by
sharing it it was simply sold to Rene in
other words during the 90s in the 2000s
the ruling elite in Romania did whatever
they could importer to keep control of
the economy and the country it was only
through these actions that they were
able to keep a hold on their power
[Music]
wait just a second here because
corruption was present at lower levels
as well in a country that had been so
used to scarcity it was impossible to
get anything without a little brine you
want to go to the doctor well bring a
box of cigarettes with you and what
about to have electricity at home
whiskey bottled men's everything sorted
out and that is how in this country
corruption became a way of life
[Music]
and now you might be wondering is it
really possible for a country to work
this way and the answer is well no
Romanians saw how our the former
communist republics such as the Czech
Republic or Poland started enjoying a
Western standard of living while they
kept surviving on less than $400 a month
this is why in the middle of 2000
Romania requested to become a member of
the European Union so that they could
get access to some of those sweet sweet
EU funds and Brussels basically said
okay man I'll let you in that there's
one condition and that condition was the
National anti-corruption Directorate in
the year 2002 the Romanian government
founded an agency to chase corruption
the National anti-corruption Directorate
for its first few years this agency was
directed by prosecutors connected to the
party leaders so this was basically the
Romanian way of saying hey brothel look
at us we're doing great look at all this
corruption we're tackling with cleaning
up everything but then again not
surprisingly nothing changed that was
until the year 2013 that is the year
when a woman came to lead the
directorate a woman ready to face
everything and everyone and her name is
laura kadru Zhirkov AC
Damien's seemed to have been impressed
by the activities of the DNA according
to one recent poll 60% of people said
they trusted the agency while only 11
percent say they trusted program in just
two years because they see his jails
more than 1100 politicians accused of
corruption during these years Romanians
have discovered all of the dirty things
their ruling class were hiding and these
are no small things according to an
estimate corruption accounts for 15% of
Romanian GDP virtually all the public
sales had some kind of right involved
even the Microsoft licenses that the
civil servants used at a cost of over 3
million dollars which were used to pay
bribes to different government official
[Music]
then there was the case of a judge who
was paid around seven hundred thousand
dollars in order to declare someone
innocent who is actually guilty and look
this list it just goes on and on and on
and I don't want to make that the rest
of this video but since the year 2013
basically all of these criminals they
think filling up the Romanian jails to
the point that some of the prisons have
no space anymore but not only that
romanian society itself has started to
realize just how damaging corruption is
but the real turning point came a little
bit later
with this news Romanian nightclub fire
leaves 27 dead this news triggered a
wave of protests all across Romania
apparently this fire could have been
avoided if the club would have met
safety regulations that since the owner
had bribed the local authorities he
could open the club without breaking the
rules this is how a platform came to be
called the corruption and chi-x or
corruption kills in English through
social media Romanians started to
organize themselves in protest groups
against corruption oh but just hold on
for a minute because the best is really
at the cup
the biggest demonstrations in Romanian
history on January 18th 2017 at 10 p.m.
the social democratic government and its
prime minister Soren grinde anno passed
an emergency bill and yes they did do it
at night when everyone was about to go
to bed so what did this decree say well
it said the politicians who accepted
bribes for less than 44 thousand euros
did not have to say jail time or pay any
fines nothing at all it was absolutely
fine with the law to be bribed up to
that amount and if you like if you
notice that they discussed this little
well debating the national budget as
normal phone no one would notice the
change so now you might be wondering who
can possibly dare to pass such a bold
law I mean what could possibly be the
official reason behind the
decriminalization of bribery well this
is the reason given by the Romanian
Prime Minister wants to pass the
ordinances into law to ease overcrowding
in prisons yes this was the actual
reason given by the Romanian government
and spin just like that over 3,000
corrupt politicians could be freed and
he has well it is true the Romanian
jails are overcrowded in a country where
money is drained from the system by
bribery it shouldn't be too difficult to
find new funds for new prisons also the
Faculty majority of the jail's
politicians belong to the government
party does make it slightly more
suspicious don't you think well half a
million Romanians thought so too and
they took to the streets of Bucharest
minutes after the decree with paths from
these people
feels that they've been cheated that
these people the smoothie previously
established corruption kills platform
citizens learned about this news
instantly and why they did not like it
at all and that is how the biggest
protest in Romanian history started
I never dared to think that this was
possible I've always thought there was
some logic some common sense that would
lead to a valid law but when I saw what
happened I knew I was wrong the protests
kept going for days not only in
Bucharest but in most Romanian cities
the first victim of the unrest was the
Justice Minister who was forced to
resign on the 9th of February 2017 as we
mentioned the protests led to the
government retiring this new law
although they have already admitted that
this is just temporary further the
brand-new justice minister to darrell's
Jota has a clear mission to justify the
firing of the general prosecutor Laura
could researcher they seemed women who
jailed over 1,000 politicians the
government claims that her agency is
running a witch but they still haven't
found a way to legally fire her yet
after evaluating all the
constitutionality legality and
opportunity factors I determined that at
the moment it's not advisable to start
the institutional mechanism to revoke
the general prosecutor and the DNA chief
prosecutor at the same time Grinde Ana's
government is confronted by two
different sites on the one hand civil
society is surveying his movements on
the other hand the European Union is
demanding that he stop obstructing the
anti-corruption prosecutor and of course
all of the political elite inheritors of
Ceausescu's regime are turning to
classic conspiracy theories do protect
themselves according to them George
Soros and the Rothschild family are
behind the protesters and they say of
course that corruption is not actually a
big deal in Romania at all well with or
without conspiracies we are still
talking about an existential crisis in
Europe third poorest country
so now the question is do you think
Romania should jail all of their
corrupted politicians or do you think
that instead the Prime Minister is
actually doing something right by
decriminalizing bribery you can leave
your answer in the comment section below
[Music]
antek eight you want to hear another
story about a citizen revolution you
might want to check out our video where
we tell you about the umbrella
revolution in Hong Kong click on that
right there and also don't forget to
visit our friends that we consider
mediacom who provided the voice in this
video that isn't mine and please give us
a thumbs up if you enjoyed that video
and don't forget we put our brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday so do
subscribe to not miss out on any of them
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]